a rollicking interview between Hannity
and Giuliani just concluding and the
former New York City Mayor and newly
appointed Trump attorney dishing on the
Trump legal strategy Jim Comey Bob
Muller and whether the president will
submit to a special counsel interview
and even revealing a new detail that has
the left going nuts tonight about the
alleged stormy Daniels payout now we're
going to break it all down for you
tonight there's a lot to get to so let's
first hear Rudy on where a potential
Trump interview with Muller's team
stands we're gonna have to decide
probably it falls more on us because
he's on the government side whether the
president should grant an interview
here's what it's all about it's real
simple and American people can follow
this along with me are they objective
are they well right now a lot of things
point in the in the direction of they
made up their mind that Comey is telling
the truth and not the president when you
look at those questions about what does
the president think what does the
president feel what does the president
really desire those are all questions
intended to trap him now to help us
unpack this
let's bring in Byron York here in
Washington in Miami attorney Harmeet
Dillon and in Arizona congressman Andy
Biggs a member of the house freedom
caucus and Judiciary Committee guys we
have a lot to get through tonight
congressman Biggs I want to start with
you first I hope you were able to watch
that interview with Rudy what struck you
about what he said about about Comey
Muller in the entire year of
Investigation Mania well I think my
impression is that he's got it right and
my frustration is that we've gone a year
and there's no actus reus knows there's
no criminal activity there's no culpable
mental state going on here and this is
just that Muller investigation is not
objective and that that really resonates
with me because it's not objective it's
biased and they're trying to use these
questions in this interview is going to
be
trap fest for for come--and actually I'm
4 molar against the president and it
gets to the whole thing they just want
to go after President Trump
all right Byron there's so much to
unpack this is what Rudy said about the
state of the investigation and whether
it should wrap up let's watch
I believe that Attorney General Sessions
my good friend and Rosenstein who I
don't know I believe they should in the
interest of justice in this
investigation there's been too much
government misconduct the crimes now
have all been committed by the
government
wow that was that was that was a moment
the crimes have been committed by the
government and I watched him I thought
boy we he would have made an interesting
Attorney General pick wouldn't he no
kidding I think we have seen in the last
24 hours since the release of these
proposed questions from Muller and now
with this rudy interview on hannity i
think we've seen a dramatic change in
this case i mean it's become much more
confrontational the lawyers John Dowd
and Ty Cobb who were counseling a more
conciliatory approach toward Muller they
are now gone and we I mean we've just
had the president's lawyer go on TV for
an hour I mean you didn't see Dow toward
Cobb doing that and basically also you
the one thing that Rudy said was he
thinks the odds are against the
president Trump actually sitting down
and talking with Muller so they they
made a lot of news in the last 24 hours
they're ramping it up and Monico their
army Dylan on with us Harmeet here's the
deal we have had a string of attorneys
with the president and in Ty Cobb he's
leaving at the end of May
of course John Dowd he exited in March
there was and there still is Marty and
Jane Raskin recently brought on the team
Casa wits his personal attorney one of
his personal attorneys he was in and out
briefly last year but now they bring in
Emmett flood now in full disclosure
Emmett and I were Koch lurks back in the
day on the Second Circuit Court of
Appeals you see him up on the upper
left-hand corner
flood is the kind of attorney who is
probably not going to give a lot of
interviews on television is one of the
smartest people I know one of the finest
people I know and just top-notch kind of
person he should have been brought in
right from the very beginning in this
case but to bring him in who worked for
for the Clinton during the impeachment
investigation he's at Williams and
Connelly this does tell you that I think
finally the Trump team has gotten really
serious at Muller doesn't that
tiddlywinks here while there's going to
go for the big for the big get here your
reaction yeah absolutely Laura I
completely agree with you Emmett flood
is a great addition to the team and it
wasn't just Clinton he also has
represented dick comb Dick Cheney in
private practice and he also was in the
White House counsel's office and did
investigation under the Bush
administration as well so he's played
both he's you know he's got experience
in both types of administrations and
what they're signalling here is by
picking somebody with impeachment
experience is that the scales have
fallen from the eyes of the White House
lawyers and they realize that the stakes
are about impeachment here there when
you see the questions in the the Muller
leaked the questions are clearly not
about any crime that the President may
have committed it's clearly doing some
free research for the Democrats with
respect to a potential impeachment trial
it could not be clearer and I'm glad as
a supporter of the President and a
lawyer to see that they finally woken up
and you know the Giuliani interview that
we just saw right now was amazing very
encouraging to me also to see somebody
with some reality check here I mean
these are not people you can trust at
their face value we have seen the crimes
we've seen the deception and we have
seen the absolute unethical conduct
that's been committed against this
president so far so I feel much more
reassured seeing them kind of smartening
up and guarding for battle here and
Congressman Big C of course the big news
yesterday was the freedom caucus which
you're a member
leaking a draft impeachment document
focused on of course rod Rosenstein the
Deputy Attorney General Rudy said look I
don't know him that was kind of a
brush-off Rosenstein just there but
they're taking it up I mean they're
taking up you guys seem to be taking it
up in the house and Rudy himself said
this
call me devastating let's watch I know
James call me I know the president sorry
Jim you're a liar a disgraceful liar
every FBI agent in America has his head
down because of you it would have been
good for God you've got it kept you out
of being a head of the FBI congressman
amen to that I you know this was one of
those comments when when he says that I
stand up and cheer because we've been
saying that we've been trying to to make
it clear they they thank goodness for
Rudy Giuliani saying that because mr.
Comey has been a disgrace he's you know
trey Gowdy said it great nobody has
brought more disrepute on the FBI than
James Comey and this this is where we
are as a nation I can't go to
constituents they are all upset what's
happening with Comey why isn't he behind
bars and and he needs to be investigated
himself look we have this moment
biron about extortion when Ron
Rosenstein yesterday said basically
we're not going to be extorted at the
Justice Department into backing down
being intimidated and today number of
editorials written and columns written
there was one in USA Today by two
prominent Democrats a former Obama
official and Fred Wertheimer at the
Brookings Institution saying the freedom
caucus and the Republicans are doing the
bidding of the president trying to
intimidate the special counsels office
it's a disgrace I mean if it was hot
before it's being ramped up now big time
on both sides those who are real go to
war words the whole extortion thing and
there are people in the Justice
Department who are unhappy with the
Attorney General and with rod Rosen
Stein you feel they've given too much to
Congress but on this thing I cannot say
that the Justice Department should hand
over every single document to Congress
not saying that but Rosenstein would
have more credibility today if he had
not made getting documents from the
Justice Department the FBI like pulling
teeth for Congress over the last year
Paul Ryan is not a big warrior in this
kind of thing and he said the FBI
was stonewalling Congress the house
representatives on this so they don't
have a lot of room to talk now that
they're complaining and Giuliani said
her me that when he was asked by Hannity
are there two systems of justice in this
country
Rudy jumped right on it and said yeah
one for Hillary and one for everybody
else one for the president
I mean look he's the lawyer representing
the president but for a lot of Americans
who are watching this you destroyed
documents you distribute emails you
smash blackberries everyone gets
immunity you get to do an interview that
really cozy right before the fourth of
July no transcript taken never under
oath and then look at what's happened on
the other side to this president for a
year with all this important stuff
happening in the world
he has been hounded by a special counsel
whose office is populated by partisans
who not are just Democrats but have an
animus toward this president and I III
have to say when I heard Rudy said that
I said well I have to say I agree I mean
all that all the evidence points to that
yet Laura I would actually say there are
three systems of government here there's
one for Hillary there's one for normal
schmoes in the world and then there's
especially heinous one for president
Trump I mean from day one from from
clapper telling Co me to go brief the
President on this non-existent Russia
drama to giving news hook to Jake Tapper
and CNN on down to the to the incident
that that Giuliani recounted where
Muller was interviewed by the president
for the job of FBI director with
Rosenstein Rosenstein sitting next to
him and and then they walk out in a
couple of days later knowing that the
president has rejected him for that job
Rosen Stein picks that very person I
mean the deck is stacked with partisans
people with access to grind and I think
that the the mass really fell yesterday
when Rosen Stein's angry words came out
made it really personal and you know who
does he think he is he works for the
president he's an inferior officer of
the United States executive branch
working ultimately for the president I
was just shocked and just like FBI
agents are hanging their heads
shame I'm sure so there's a lot of good
attorneys at the Department of Justice
I better stunned that the that people
are picking a fight with their bosses
like this on television it was night
Frank I tweeted this a couple of minutes
ago but I think one of the big of course
one of the big moments in this interview
was when Giuliani referenced the stormy
Daniels issue I believe we have the
soundbite let's watch having something
to do with paying some stormy Daniels
woman 130,000 I mean which is going to
turn out to be perfectly legal that
money was not campaign money sorry I'm
giving you a fact now that you don't
know it's not campaign money no campaign
finance violation so they funneled it
through the law firm funnel throw over
him and the president repaid it okay on
April 6th of this year on Air Force One
this was the exchange
[Music]
okay so it's hard to hear there but he
said no I didn't know about it and then
he said you're gonna have to ask Michael
Cohen about the payment now I was
putting my legal head on during the
break and I thought well maybe did did
Trump pay it after April 6 I don't know
but that to me Byron York the left is
jumping all over that tonight saying
what the heck he didn't know he didn't
know Rudy's on TV what's going on well
these are real questions Rudy he just
gave us a completely different version
of this but unless the president paid it
after April 6 which maybe he did but it
appears that what Giuliani was saying
first of all he said paying some money
get some money to be quiet to be quiet
is not a criminal act that's okay and
there was no campaign finance violations
no that's where it's gone so it appears
to me that the real concern is that
there would be a campaign of finance
vulnerability on this have the president
on tape on Air Force One saying he did
not know about the payment and you'll
have to ask Michael Cohen about that
Rudy just goes on with Hannity and says
don't know he's very embarrassed I'm
like well first of all they may not have
thought this whole thing through okay
you better think it through that's why I
met floods probably not gonna do a lot
of interviews I love Rudy but they
better have an explanation for that
that's it that's a that's a problem they
decided that the campaign finance
vulnerability was bigger okay you know
you can chime in on that congressman
Biggs but welcome I was a criminal
defense lawyer this is what I did I was
always looking for inconsistencies and
statements like any lawyer would there
may be an explanation for this and I
think we'll we'll probably hear one but
the left is gonna seize on that it's all
about credibility and impeaching
someone's credibility throughout the
process so if you're if you're not being
if you're not being truthful about this
and are you being truthful about the
Russians I mean you can just see where
this is gonna go go ahead well well
that's right but there's two two points
to that that's coming from the side
that's just been lying and and abusing
their power all the way throughout so
that I immediately discount that the
second thing is I don't think somebody
with president Trump's income level
actually maybe writes all his checks you
know what I mean it
it would not surprise me if if yes he
authorised the payment and you know it
just gets kind of lost in the shuffle I
know that sounds crazy perhaps on a
certain level but I mean here's a guy
with a massive an income and he's
dealing with a lot of things and you
know it's not illegal it's not campaign
finance that's all I agree at all I
think you're right on all that but I
mean again we have to bring out all
issues we're doing we're doing an honest
broker conversation about what's
happened overwhelmingly biased against
this president this investigation we've
established this week after week after
week on the show the best legal minds in
the United States and we got it we got
to be fair and focusing on what seems to
be not kind of adding up on another
point but I read I want to go to you and
Byron I want you to comment on this as
well when Rudy was asked about whether
the president should testify under oath
videotape do you know every one Clinton
did that and it was Saul Weisenberger
did the questioning back in the
Whitewater day that presented some
problems for the president but let's
watch I would like to get one not under
oath I'd wanted a videotaped and I'm not
videotaping audio tapes okay I want to
make sure they don't misrepresent his
answers but this is an outrageous
miscarriage of justice
Harmeet well first of all we know that
Hillary Clinton when she was interviewed
by the FBI had no transcription and had
immunized witnesses in the room we
shouldn't have been immunized they're
all guilty of crimes themselves
apparently and not under oath and it was
sort of very friendly you know up and
done now as a lawyer we know when we
even as junior associates the worst
potential witnesses are very powerful
people because they're used to getting
their way they're used to not being
questioned and and so they're typically
the ones who need the most preparation
so the Trudy was saying is going to need
a couple of days I would say a couple of
weeks of preparation for interview and
there is no justification
one more point though that your viewers
should know is that the FBI has gotten
into the habit particularly if they want
to you know get somebody for a crime
they don't record it I mean you would
the opposite is true right if you're a
good investigator and you want to make
sure you have the evidence you have a
contemporaneous recording this has
gotten the FBI in a trouble and has
resulted in a lot of convictions being
vacated over the years on a pure
interest because the evidence the
evidence doesn't match up and so it I
agree with Rudy that it need there needs
to be a record of it I just overall
though I questioned whether he should
know the buyer in the way that we said
he got it Biron last word oh the whole
point was trying to limit this thing
Rudy said no more than two hours the
number of questions that were released
just how do you feel how did you feel
when you did the interview with Maria
Bartiromo I mean I'm paraphrasing but it
was basically that that could easily
have been two days of questioning not
not talking about the preparation two
days of actual questioning so he
definitely wanted to to limit that they
wouldn't mind doing it in writing if
they could but he said Muller wouldn't
go for that so right now they're in they
try to limit it phase before they get
into the know I'm not gonna talk phase
yeah I think the good news is Emmett
flood is on board I literally cannot
think maybe one other lawyer I could
think of would be just as good if not
better than Emmett but that that's
awesome news for president Trump and a
sign that things are indeed very very
serious great panel guys thank you so
much